(dynamic music)
The closed mind is not driven
because the closed mind is certain.
I believe that everyone has a purpose.
You know, once you have your purpose and your clarity,
you can show up with intention.
But the ultimate end result
of pursuing dopamine
is to feel worse than when you started.
For me, compassion is strength.
Sometimes you have to fail
in order to be your best version of self.
Greetings and happy holidays from everyone here
at the RRP mothership.
Welcome to the show where for the last nine years,
I have endeavored to have deep, meaningful,
long form conversations
about things that matter with a wide swath
of the world's best and brightest minds,
discussing everything from fitness and education,
science, nutrition, and environmentalism,
to arts, spirituality, literature,
entrepreneurship, athleticism, creativity,
and positive culture change.
And this past year was no different
despite 2021 being a year that we can all safely label
as challenging for a variety of reasons.
I yet find myself full of gratitude
for the just astounding number
of incredible evergreen conversations
we were able to produce and gift to you
over the course of the past 12 months.
And so as the Earth has made its way
back to this fateful position,
having made yet another miraculous track around the sun,
it is time once again to prepare for the coming new year,
by taking time to pause, to breathe,
and to reflect, to take inventory
of where you were last year
in order to celebrate victories,
deconstruct setbacks, and set goals
for who you wanna be when we all find ourselves
in this same celestial position
12 months from now.
I believe in this annual practice
that the blank slate 2022 represents
can bring the hope and inspiration
required to make our goals a reality.
And so it is in this spirit
that we indulge in annual tradition here at the podcast
to end each year with a two-part compilation
of the finest podcast excerpts
from the previous 12 months of the show,
full episodes of which can be found in the show notes
on the episode page at richroll.com.
Think of these next two episodes
as both a refresher course
for the devoted RRP fans
and also as an anthology for those of you
who are brand new to the show.
So hit that subscribe button
and let's kick off this best of
with the man who got the year started,
former Navy Seal Commander, Rich Diviney.
On the pod to promote his book, "The Attributes",
Rich delivered an incredibly powerful primer
on how your attributes determine life outcomes
and how you can train said disposition
to create more optimal performance
in all areas of your life.
So here it is from episode 571, Rich Diviney.
How is my life better now in 2021,
in January 2021 than it was in January 2020?
Admittedly, that might take some thought, right?
But you will come up with answers.
One of the best ways to put yourself in the proper state,
and I love this question which is
ask what you're grateful for.
Gratitude also is
an enormously powerful chemical combination
when you are truly grateful.
You're getting oxytocin, you're getting DHEA,
you're getting dopamine.
Asking yourselves what am I grateful for now
is a great way in.
So then you say, okay, what are some of those things
I learned, what are the things I have to think about
going into 2021?
Okay, well, it's gonna be uncertain. We know that.
So when I think about my good attributes,
I'm gonna need a little bit of courage.
If I feel like I'm low on courage,
I should probably try to develop that a little bit.
I'm definitely gonna need adaptability.
Perseverance, okay, I have some goals.
Obviously my goals might've been derailed in January 2020.
Okay, now what do I do?
What are the things I can do to persevere
and affect my goals in 2021 no matter what happens?
And how am I going to adapt to do that?
I think an enormously important,
in fact, if I were to scale them,
I'd probably say one of the most important attributes
that we can all focus on in 2021 is open-mindedness.
Open-mindedness again, the closed mind
is not driven because the closed mind is certain.
And certain minds aren't curious
and they're not seeking what's next.
They aren't seeking what could be.
And if 2020 taught us anything,
is that we don't know.
You know, we don't know what's coming down the pike.
And if we're open-minded enough
to start understanding, okay, I'm going to take...
Now, this is a passive, it's a passive activity.
You know, optimism is,
I would call optimism proactive pathway.
Open-mindedness as a passive pathway
where you say, okay, I am going to be open
to other ideas, viewpoints, situations
so that I can try to look at them
from a positive, not necessarily positive,
but a proactive and an effective lens.
But there's a difference between making that decision
and actually effectuating it, right?
There is.
You can say I'm open-minded
but then you find yourself in a situation
and you're very much not open-minded.
Yeah, yeah.
And I think we all found ourselves
in that situation in 2020.
And again, I come back to this idea of asking questions.
It's all, ultimately it comes down to the questions
we ask ourselves.
If we find ourselves in a situation where we're feeling
like, okay, this person I'm talking to
seems to be of complete opposite political beliefs than me,
how might I be wrong?
What might this person be feeling?
What might this person be experiencing that I'm not?
You start to tap into empathy certainly.
But again, empathy is about feeling what that person feels.
That's a little bit more of a leap, you know,
but you can certainly start having a perspective
without necessarily feeling it.
And I think of it-
Curiosity.
Curiosity. Curiosity is the buttress
to open-mindedness, absolutely.
But I'd say, some people are more naturally curious
than others and most of those people
are automatically open-minded.
So the reason why I didn't put curiosity there
is because I think open-mindedness
can be accessed by almost anybody
just by asking the right question.
Can I just, let me give this person, this situation,
this event a chance, and and let me start seeing
what might be positive about that.
Let me see it in a different light, you know.
Take myself out of my own perspective.
If I'm not
this 47-year-old male,
former Navy Seal, author, living in Virginia,
if I'm not that person, then how does this look?
And those are really powerful questions to ask
and ones that can help open your mind quite a bit.
The best news of all is we all have uncertainty
and challenge and strife in our lives
and those are wonderful crucibles
inside of which we can start understanding ourselves.
Yeah.
Next up is storytelling superstar Joanne Molinaro,
aka the Korean Vegan,
in an excerpt from episode 632,
where we trace her path to a plant-based diet,
the many ways in which food
and social justice advocacy intersect,
and the importance of humanizing the immigrant experience
specifically through her beautiful
and moving videos on TikTok.
My biggest value is compassion.
I feel like it is one of the most underrated characteristics
in the world.
And I feel like people think that compassion is weakness
or compassion is crying or too much empathy.
And for me, compassion is strength.
It's the strongest thing that you could do
is to be compassionate.
So fundamentally the Korean Vegan in its current version
is about compassion in every way.
What role do you think that hardship and challenge
plays in the kind of cauldron
those formative experiences that lead
to like the kind of resonance that you need
to understand your own story
and really grasp the power that it might hold
to be transformative for others.
So I always think about sort of the crucible, right?
I was actually thinking about that this morning.
I was like, that is-
You were thinking about a lot of things this morning.
Oh yeah. Well, this-
You're like,
"Just this morning" you know,
like among the 7,000 other things
you said you were thinking about this morning.
I was running, I was running this morning
and I was like, this is what my brain goes through.
But I was thinking about the crucible
and how that's such a great metaphor for my life, right?
And how I had to go through this period
of what I call the dark ages of my life
in order to come out and be the person that I am today.
And what that period in my life
has afforded me
is, again, the fundamental of the Korean Vegan
which is compassion.
The most important thing
I feel like in the whole world is compassion.
And I can now relate
to a lot of different kinds
of pains and struggles
because I went through what I did.
And what I'm trying to convey
through the Korean Vegan
is the sense of, hey, I understand your pain.
I understand your struggle.
And if I don't, then I'm here to listen to that struggle.
I'm here to be a safe space for your pain
and your struggle.
Because you need to feel like you're listened to
and that you will be safe
if you are going to be empowered
to execute on that next chapter of your life,
to come out of that crucible stronger.
And, you know, my own story is really that.
Went through really difficult time
in the earlier years of my life
and now I'm deliriously happy
and always seeking out the pockets of joy in every day.
And I don't know that I would be able
to appreciate joy the way that I do
without having gone through what I did
in that crucible.
Yeah.
You know, like sometimes you have to fail
in order to be your best version of self
at some point in the future.
So don't be so afraid of failure.
That's a necessary component to the crucible.
You gotta go through some of that in order to know
where you're going to succeed and really shine.
And that's certainly something that resonated with me a lot
is thinking about how I've kind of had my finger
in a lot of different things and maybe that's the reason
I'm Joanne and nobody else is.
I mean, it sounds very trite and banal in some respects,
but it's also simply beautiful.
I want to leave this place more wonderful
than it was when I came into it.
And I don't, right now sitting here today,
thinking about when this podcast is airing, (chuckles)
I'm not sure that that's me as a lawyer, you know.
I really don't think that makes sense.
I think that what I'm, the feedback that I've received
over the past seven to eight months
is no, I can do a lot more in that regard
as the Korean Vegan.
And I don't even know what that is right now,
because it hasn't seen its full potential.
Sure.
I've never been able
to identify it.
And you don't need to know.
In a powerful addition to the Coach's Corner series,
Olympians Chris Hauth and Caroline Burckle joined me
in episode 595 for a roundtable discussion
on the power of endurance training
as a tool for self-actualization.
It's really stuck with me.
Here is a slice of that conversation.
To speak more towards the purpose,
it's my enjoyment lies 100%
in helping others get that sort of deep understanding
of their why or their purpose or their path.
I mean, the biggest frustration
that many athletes that come to me have
is that I keep telling them it will appear for you.
Do not try to force it.
You know, you can't manipulate your life path.
And they don't wanna hear that.
And it takes a few years,
and then they'll come back and go,
"You know what, you were sort of right back then.
I'm ready to take that journey now."
But my power meter says this, Chris,
and I need it to say this.
Yes, but the only way it's gonna say that
is if you let go and let, you know,
it's like we know from swimming.
It's like whenever we're too tight,
(stammers) today this set is gonna be so intense.
Like you try to get yourself mentally ready for it
and then you get there and you're three or four repeats in
and you're nervous and you're not swimming well,
and your walls are awful,
and you're just like chopping through the water.
And then it's like,
"What am I making such a big deal out of this?"
And then slowly you return into what you're capable of.
And that's the hardest part, that dichotomy.
Caring enough for the result and the outcome,
but also letting go enough
for letting the result and outcome to happen for you.
The Eckhart Tolle.
Yeah, hat's literally my favorite.
Right now I'm living in a space of possibilities
on both sides of everything, like both things can be true.
And I don't work with older athletes like you do,
but the younger generation, these teenagers,
it's the same thing.
It's like this I don't want to let go of that control
because if I let go of that control,
then I'm gonna fail.
I have, then my confidence will go down the drain.
All of these other things
that people just hold on so tightly to,
and to let go
is such a physical experience too
that you have to experience through your body,
which I'm a big fan of just that whole conversation.
But I think we try to use our minds
to wrap around that
to where it's like, I'm just gonna let go with my mind.
And then yes, we can let go with our minds
but then we're just, our bodies are still tense
and our minds are trying to let go
and conceptualize this thing
that we haven't actually experienced
through our whole physical being,
which I think quarantine has allowed people
to tap in to themselves in a different way,
because they don't have that physical outlet
in the same way
so they have to release physically through other modalities.
I think that that's an appropriate kinda place
to segue into something you were talking about
in your podcast the other day,
which is this idea, well, two ideas,
the first being
to think about not just working out,
but working in,
which is kind of what we've already been talking about.
But also this idea of showing up is not enough.
Like where is the intentionality that you're bringing
to what it is that you're doing?
And of course this is something that's applicable
to any athlete, how they're approaching
their training regimen,
but in life to whatever it is that we're doing,
particularly now where everything has been upended
and it's causing confusion and anxiety,
and we're all kind of asking ourselves questions
about like, "Why am I doing this?"
Yeah.
Like we're all being-
Reevaluating, yeah.
Yeah, we're all,
everybody's re-evaluating in their own way right now.
Yeah, but that's part of what I go into there.
And that is once you have your purpose and your clarity,
you can show up with intention
because you're not questioning the goals.
You're not questioning the path.
Now you can focus all your attention
onto executing the next workout,
the next day at work, this project
to the best of your ability,
'cause you're not wondering, well, why am I,
you don't wanna be asking, why am I doing this?
'Cause that takes everything that you have
in that workout or in that project
or that vacation with your family,
you show up with intention too.
Like, if you start wondering, why am I here,
you're not gonna have a good vacation.
You're not gonna have a good workout.
You're not gonna have a good work outcome.
And so the big thing there
is once you have the bigger picture, the purpose,
and once you have the clarity,
which is what I call the coaching,
the path, the manual, the sort of map,
then you can execute the workout properly.
You can execute your training without wondering,
why am I doing this?
How is this gonna help me?
Is this keeping me on my path
towards my desired outcome?
And is this what the coach and I discussed?
It's all been laid out already.
And we know that from swimming,
we're just so ingrained in this
that we don't, well, of course these 400 IMs
are helping me swim my 400 IM better.
Of course, this set of 200s
with the middle hundred fly is helping me swim
my 400 IM better.
But in the endurance training world
or in just in the work world,
if you don't know where you're heading
and why you're doing it,
the quality of your work is always going to be limited
because you're just constantly wasting cognitive energy,
cognitive load as they call it,
on other things in order to make it more intentional
and clear for you.
Once you have that out, you can hit flow.
You're right in the moment because you're not worried
about all the other things
'cause they've been clarified for you.
The scaffolding is set.
And what I mean by that is when we start training,
especially as masters athletes,
not when we're younger,
but as, the training is a scaffolding.
What happens inside that scaffolding
is unique to everybody.
I might be doing a lot of mental work.
Other people might be doing physical work.
Other people are doing spiritual work.
The training is the placeholder
and what's being rebuilt in that building,
is it a complete rebuild.,
is it some sort of remodeling, right?
But the training
sets up the opportunity every day
to spend time with yourself.
And you might not want go in that day.
Might just sort of, you know, do a little paint job.
But other days you're like knocking down walls
and you are doing some serious work inside
and the tears come or the aha moment comes,
and you're like, "Wow, I hadn't realized
how badly I am avoiding."
Or you're listening to a podcast and something you say,
for example, just triggers something.
Boom, pause the podcast,
keep rolling and just work with that sentence
or with that emotion that just came up.
But again, I think it's important that that curiosity
sets up the training, the scaffolding
so that you have an opportunity every day
or every few days if you're not training every day,
to sort of do that working in and working out.
Yeah, I like that.
When vegan transcontinental runner Hellah Sidibe
ran across America,
I was instantly taken by his incredible energy
and immediately got to work to book him on the show.
We spoke of his four plus year run streak
and why mindset and service are key to his success.
But more than anything else,
it's Hellah's infectious positivity
that makes this one of the best of the year.
Here's the snippet from our exchange from episode 612.
I literally told myself one day
I'm tired of making excuses.
(Rich laughing)
I gotta do something
that I can hold myself accountable for.
And then fitness comes to your mind. You're an athlete.
And I said, "Hellah, whenever you tell yourself
you're gonna go to the gym for a week straight,
you go two, three days, you tap out."
And I said, "What is something that I'm afraid of?"
Running hit me immediately.
So playing Division I, even at the pro-level,
running, I was always afraid of it.
At UMass Amherst, the track team used to look at us,
"Are you guys," the UMass track team,
"you guys run so much."
Our coach was very proud. May he rest in peace.
Sam Cook was very proud to say,
"You guys are gonna be the fittest team in the country."
So anything you do, any mistake, "On the line."
We want to play top teams,
the day before he makes us run.
So I was, fitness test, I was afraid of it.
I couldn't sleep the night before.
I could play 90 minutes, no problem.
Because with soccer, you're heading, 50/50 ball,
you're attacking, you're defending.
It's not just solely focused on running.
So I asked myself, "What are you afraid of?"
And running hit me.
And I said, "You know what,
I'm gonna go face my fear, running.
Let me just go 10 minutes a day for two weeks
and zero pressure."
It doesn't matter if 10 minutes mean
you don't even get to a mile, that's okay.
So I told myself that.
Within the first week I fell in love with it immediately.
So I ran to Alexa Torres, my fiancee, I was like,
"I think I can do this for the rest of my life,
but I don't wanna get ahead of myself.
Let me do this every day for a year."
So that's how the whole run streak started.
Right, so it was really born out
of this frustration-
Yes, absolutely.
and a little bit of confusion
about what the next chapter was gonna look like.
Yes, exactly, exactly. That's how it all started.
It's also interesting that your frame on running
is through the lens of punishment.
When you are on a sports team that's not run specific,
it's like that's, you know,
being told to run is what happens when you get in trouble.
Literally, yeah.
Or you know,
it's like the stick.
If it has two minutes of mine,
I get so stressed the night before a fitness test.
They can see it.
They're like, "Hellah, are you okay?"
I'm like, "I just can't stop thinking
about that beep test tomorrow morning." (chuckles)
Or like the Cooper test where you gotta run two miles
under 12 minutes.
And if you don't make those times,
you gotta be in Breakfast Club,
which is extra fitness before the actual practice.
And the actual practice has its own fitness in it.
So it really got me all confused and scared and petrified.
Always to me.
But you're super fit
so when you started this streak,
I think you said you went out and ran 10 minutes
or something like that.
Yeah, it was
10 minutes a day.
But you-
That was the goal.
were certainly capable
of doing more than that.
Yeah, way capable.
And that 10 minutes didn't even last.
It was just the first week I ended up
finding myself running even four miles.
But the whole point of that idea of saying 10 minutes a day
was to have zero pressure.
'Cause I knew if I were to tell myself,
"Hellah, you gotta run at least five miles a day,"
that's something at that point in my mentality
and physical ability for running,
it wasn't something I was kind of capable of maintaining,
but I knew it was something attainable to do 10 minutes.
So it was a mental thing.
So that made me feel like,
okay, you're doing this with no pressure, enjoying.
Spring was in the air. It was May 15th, 2017.
So it was just a perfect amount of time
for me to be out there.
So that's why I said 10 minutes.
Streaks are so interesting psychologically, right?
I think it's really powerful to talk
about setting a really low bar
if you're contemplating something like that
and making it doable-
Yeah. Yes.
so that you can actually learn to enjoy it
before it becomes too challenging-
Exactly.
where you're gonna
pull the rip cord
before you've even gotten out of the gate.
Yeah.
But once you develop a little bit of momentum,
it becomes like this self-perpetuating thing.
Right?
Yes. Exactly.
I don't know Why that is.
It's that thing,
and I've said it many times before,
when you're going to the gym consistently,
it's just easier to go.
Yes.
Or if you're running every day, it's easier
Each day get it done.
to get out and run.
But if you break that cycle,
if you interrupt it even once-
Oh man. (chuckles)
then you just create all kinds of anxiety
and strain on yourself-
Everything.
that makes it so difficult.
Yeah the starting over thinking and all that.
So it's very true. Exactly how you said it.
Right, so when you first began this,
was the idea of a streak even in your mind,
or you're just like, I'm gonna go out and run
'cause I wanna be able to have
some control over myself.
It wasn't even a streak.
It was just two weeks that I needed to do.
And the thing is to my knowledge,
I didn't know what streaking actually was for running.
I didn't even know it was a thing in the running community.
I was so new to the running community.
But just for the record,
we're not talking about running naked.
(both laughing)
Yes, it's not running-
It's about running
consecutive days in a row.
Consecutively, yes.
Yes. Yeah, that's a good point. (indistinct)
(both laughing)
Yeah, so I was very ignorant to it, didn't know.
And that was really good.
I'm glad I didn't know about it
because also that would have been, oh, people streak?
That's another pressure that I didn't need.
So I didn't even know.
And it was just to get out there
and I just knew I wanted to do it every day now for a year.
Is there a whole world of people
who do these streaks out there
that have documented them?
I discovered...
Not document.
I think we humbly we became on HellahGood,
like my YouTube channel, and with my fiancee,
'cause it's a team,
we became basically the first people
to really put it on a platform of running every day
and running every day for a year, 365 days.
And now, everybody that weren't doing it, starting to do it,
everybody that weren't actually been doing it
started documenting it and push it out.
And which I'm so happy about because I actually am happier
for more people who are doing the streak
compared to me because a lot of questions comes,
"Oh, he's the lucky one. How is he able to do it?"
But when I see someone else do it,
I'm like, "See, it's not just me.
Look at this person did it, that person did it."
When you made your 365 day, your one year streak video,
most of that video was clips of other people out running
in different parts of the world.
Exactly, 'cause I realized
how much running brought us together.
And we started building a community
and I wanted to show that to people
and talk about my story of how running every day
changed my life and how people became a part of it.
So to me, it's all about the people.
I think people make the experience.
You could do a lot of stuff by yourself,
but without the people, I feel like it's not the same.
Right, well, at first it becomes this journey
of self-discovery-
Yes.
and an exploration of your own
personal potential.
Exactly.
But at some point it becomes rote
and it has to become about something else
in order to maintain-
Yes.
its meaningfulness.
I agree with you hundred percent, yeah.
So you start this thing off. You're you're doing it.
You're not sharing anything about it
until you reach a certain point
and then you decide to kind of break public
in this whole thing.
Actually, that's a good point to bring up
because for me, this was not meant for social media.
It was just for myself and it was like,
I call her Belle, my fiancee,
when I started this running streak, she was like,
"I think we gotta do a YouTube video. This is really cool.
You're running everyday. And you're going for a year.
People need to hear about this."
I keep pushing it off. I was always pushing it out.
So on day 163, she came to me and she said,
"Hey, do you wanna do a YouTube video on this?"
So I was like, "All right, fine.
You keep asking. Let's just do it."
I had just done my run for the day.
So I said, "Can I just go to the barber shop
and get my hair cut and get this like nice face
so I can look pretty in front of the camera?"
And then I went to get my hair cut, came back,
and we did a video, and the title was,
"Why I Run Every Day, Day 163".
And I started explaining to people.
So that video actually sat on YouTube for a month or two.
Wasn't a lot of views. Couple, maybe 20, 30 views.
So one morning I woke up, it was like 2000 views overnight.
And I went, I was like, "Belle, look at this.
This is really weird. Why is this catching on like this?"
And then we see 20,000 views overnight
and that kinda went mini viral
and it got over 600,000 views really quick.
And everybody's asking me,
"Are you still continuing the streak? What's happening?
Can you update us?"
So my DM on Instagram is getting flooded now.
Comments on YouTube is getting up.
So I said, "Well, let's keep updating people."
And I started doing updates,
day 254 day, day 365.
And then we just became YouTubers by accident.
So one of the things I was afraid of,
that turned into passion,
and now that turned into something bigger
than I ever imagined, yeah.
Yeah.
And Belle really drives that, right?
She, without her-
She's the one
who's doing everything.
this is not happening.
A hundred percent.
So basically she dropped whatever she's doing
to help me chase my dreams and goals.
She never went to school
for filmography or photography or anything.
She just self-taught even editing.
Just, we started doing it together
as I'm running and sharing the passion with everybody
and she's recording it
and she got better with kinda get
the content out.
You can see the evolution
from the early videos-
Yeah she...
through the present-
As of now she's (indistinct)
and how much better she's gotten at it.
And then back then we're like,
"Oh, this is awesome."
We look back and I'm like, "Oh, okay.
It looks, you definitely got so much better."
Yeah.
Uh huh.
Yeah, it's cool.
And some of those videos have millions of views now.
Yeah. A few of them went viral.
We've had all the "Running Every Day for a Year",
the "Three Years", and the "1,000 Days, "Day 802".
So we had a few of them over a few million views,
which was really cool, yeah.
So you meet the 365 goal.
You did it for a year and you're like,
I'm gonna keep going.
Yeah.
So how long had you been doing it
before The idea of running across America
came into your brain?
So it was two years in.
So after the first year, I knew I wasn't gonna stop,
but the thinking was, can I do it again?
'Cause now I know everything to expect, the season.
'Cause the goal was to be outside,
no matter the circumstances, raining, sunshine, snow,
I have to run outside.
If I go run on a treadmill, it won't count.
It's a extra run,
but it's not counting toward my streak.
I have to be outside. That was my biggest goal.
So after that second year coming up,
you knew what to expect.
So it wasn't as joyful to the first year.
Everything was new first year.
You're like, whoa, this is happening, new discovery.
And I got hurt the second year.
But in the second year it really hit me quick.
Hellah, this is bigger than yourself.
You proved to yourself that you can run every day
for a year, you're going on year two.
That's gonna be a daily routine.
Do it for something that's bigger than yourself.
So and I realized quick how running is a privilege
that not everyone has
and I wanna use that privilege of mine
to do it for something greater.
So the idea is of doing it for things even doing races.
I don't care about my own PR numbers.
I wanna have a reason to go fight for.
So if I'm dying out there,
I'm thinking about why I'm running.
So I'm sitting home one day
and came out of the shower
and I said, "I think I wanna run across the country.
Has anyone done that?"
And again, I thought I was gonna be the first one.
I have no idea. Clueless.
(Rich laughing)
And she looked at me and she goes, "Oh no."
'Cause she knows when I try to do something
now at that point I have to do it.
And she's like, "All right."
She started doing research for me.
And then that's when we discovered Robbie Ballinger.
Right.
And that's how the idea
of running every day.
Running across the country came up after a year two
when I said I needed to run across the country.
(funky rhythmic music)
(people chattering)
Olympic runner, award-winning writer, poet, filmmaker,
and dear friend, Alexi Pappas joined me
on episode 579 to discuss the courage required
to blaze your own path
as well as the self-belief needed
to set audacious goals.
And in a display of vulnerability,
how healing her past trauma taught her to thrive
and find the joy in the journey.
Here's a powerful clip from that conversation.
So much of your life was premised
on differentiating yourself from your mom,
like out of a fear that you might follow in her footsteps
in a certain way.
And I would imagine that you felt
like you had escaped that in some way,
but as the op doc shows,
and as you talk about in your book,
like, nonetheless, you have this experience with depression
in the aftermath of the Olympics most acutely,
it must have been terrifying
when that was visited upon you.
You must have thought like, "Oh my goodness,
like, am I gonna end up like my mother?"
Yeah, it was, I mean, when I started having...
I, first of all, I didn't have the vocabulary
that I tried to share in the op doc.
I didn't have that vocabulary
when I started experiencing these symptoms.
So I was in total denial that I was sick
because I didn't understand that your brain
can get injured just like your knee.
I just, I didn't understand that.
And so I was of the mindset,
as I had always been in my life,
that I needed to keep pressing forward
and fix all on my own whatever it was that I was feeling
to the point where I wasn't sleeping
but I tried to force myself to sleep.
And you know, it's called falling asleep for a reason.
You have to let it, right, let it happen.
You being a good Type A athlete,
you're trying to will everything
into existence.
Yeah.
And then I started to have these even darker thoughts
and that's when I felt like I understood my mom
in a way that I never wanted to understand her.
Like I, you have these thoughts that like,
you wanna die and I don't think
you really want to want to die,
but the thoughts say otherwise,
and that's when you're sick.
And it was terrifying because I always,
I've always been afraid my whole life
for the moment that that might happen to me.
And where that fear came from was
I have a photo book of her
when she was like teenager and she looked really happy.
And I was like, there's no way.
I just don't believe that this 16-year-old
knows what's gonna happen to her.
And that was so scary
'cause I was like, is it gonna, am I a ticking time bomb?
Does it just happen to people?
And you know, her brother took his own...
Like it runs deep in her family
so I just knew that there was a possibility.
And then when it did,
but before I understood that there was a way to get better,
I thought that that was just my fate.
That like, that was, it now happened to me.
And because the narrative I was told about her
was she just had to go, like, she just,
she was so sick that she had to go.
And I was like, well, I guess I'm so sick
that maybe I have to go.
'Cause what, I don't know what else there is.
Wow.
And that's so embarrassing honestly to share
because I don't feel that way anymore,
but I didn't understand.
And I think it's sad that even someone
who was susceptible to these things,
you know, my family history was public, right?
There was no prehab if you will,
if you wanna call,
if we wanna use this body comparison
of the brain is a body part,
I had no prehab.
I had no preparation to deal with this.
And it wasn't until my dad,
because of his experience with my mom,
made me get help that I met a doctor, Dr. Arpaia,
who told me very simply that I was sick
and that my brain had a scratch on it.
And that it could get injured like any other body part,
but it could also heal like any other body part.
And suddenly everything like it literally turned around
in a day.
Not, I wasn't happy,
but I believed that I could be on a path to healing
and that I could commit to it just like I would
an Olympic dream.
We are in a place where we can accept, I think,
as a world that elite athletes and high-achievers
can have these mental injuries, these mental illnesses.
But I think the most important thing now
is like, what do we do about them?
And that was something that I found,
I find that sometimes we point fingers
at the pinnacle institutions that we're chasing.
But actually I truly think that this kind of education
or shift has to happen much younger
and on a more universal level,
not just at those pinnacles.
So what would that look like if you were in charge
and could put those things in place?
Well, let's look at body,
the way we've approached the body
and how that's progressed
over the last, let's say 10 years.
Like 10 years ago, I don't think my dad
or my friend's little sister
would have seen a PT for their body
without having an injury,
meaning like regularly take care of their body.
And so just looking at that world,
we've come a long way to accepting
that our body is something
not only elite athletes should take care of,
but everybody should take care of
and that we should take care of it
before it's a problem ideally
if you are able to have that kind of support.
And it's not, there's just systems
and you can always, you can get that kind of help
if you can and need it, right?
And I think with mental health, the comparing it
to healing and injury
is so simple to me and makes so much sense.
So what it would look like to me is accepting honestly
that our brain is a body part and it can get injured.
And when it gets injured,
just like when we break our leg
or feel something strange in our leg,
we have no shame about sharing that something is off
and we get help and we know where to get help.
And it's either built into the system that we're in,
like a team might have a physio,
they might have a psychologist too.
Or someone can refer you to their favorite physio
or their favorite...
Like there's just more accessibility,
just like there is in the PT world.
And then we get that help
and we are as kind to ourselves as we are hard on ourselves,
knowing that it's not gonna resolve overnight.
Like nobody is demanding that somebody's broken leg
heal tomorrow and so why are we demanding
that somebody's depression heal tomorrow?
Organizational psychologist, Harvard alum,
and "New York Times" bestselling author of "Think Again",
Adam Grant graced the podcast way back on episode 580
sharing sage advice on how to engage with others
who see the world differently,
finding joy in being wrong,
and embracing the art of re-thinking.
Prepare your noodle for this one.
Right, so the idea, and this was the subject
of this "New York Times" opinion piece,
basically, that came out the other day.
The idea being that you approach these conversations
rather than from the paradigm that you outline in the book,
which is as prosecutor, as preacher, or as politician,
but rather lead with curiosity,
ask a lot of questions, and receive the answers
to those questions without judgment,
but rather more curiosity.
That's the goal.
Is that accurate?
Yeah, I think that's a great summary
of both the mindset of approaching this like a scientist
and saying, look, I'm not gonna preach that I'm right,
I'm not gonna prosecute you for being wrong,
but I'm also not gonna be a politician
and just tell you what you wanna hear
to try to campaign for your approval.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna, as a scientist,
I'm gonna say,
you know, Rich, this is totally fascinating to me
that your beliefs are so different from mine
and I genuinely wanna understand them better
and if you could help me make sense of how this works
and how this played out.
And then, I also wanna understand,
I'm sure I have some beliefs that are wrong.
I suspect you also do too, right?
Nobody's omniscient.
I'd love to understand what kind of information
would lead you to consider changing your mind.
And I'm also thrilled to talk
about what might change my mind.
And then the hope is we're both gonna find out
that our knowledge was incomplete through this conversation.
And of course it doesn't work if that's a tactic, right?
Because the other person will see right through it.
But if you adopt what counseling psychologists
call motivational interviewing,
and you really try to understand the person's reasons
for change and what would lead them
to consider shifting their opinion a little bit,
then you might surface information
that would lead them to change their own mind.
Right.
So let's dig into that a little bit deeper,
but maybe we can start with elaborating a little bit more
on this prosecutor, preacher, politician rubric
that you've set up here.
The original idea comes
from a colleague of mine, Phil Tetlock,
who's studied political psychology and social psychology
most of his career.
And Phil observed that in decision-making and judgment,
we spend a lot of time thinking
like preachers, prosecutors, and politicians.
And we're usually not aware of it when we're doing it.
A preacher mindset is essentially believing
that you've already seen the light
and now you have to go and proselytize to everybody else
and get them onboard.
So you've drunk the intellectual Kool-Aid
and now your job is to serve it.
A prosecuting mindset
is more about proving everyone else wrong
and winning your side of the case.
And then a politician mindset
is really about saying,
okay, I've got some constituents here
and I need to lobby for their buy-in.
I want their support.
And my big worry, Rich, was when I learned
about this framework, I thought,
okay, preaching and prosecuting,
those stop you from thinking again.
Because if I know I'm right and I'm sure you're wrong,
I don't need to budge in any of my opinions
or any of the knowledge that I hold.
I just need to convince you to do that.
And in politician mode,
we see people sounding a lot more flexible,
but it's really just adjusting
what they say to fit in.
It's not actually changing what they believe internally
and that's just basically flip-flopping.
Yeah, I think I fall mostly into the politicking camp
as a (chuckles)...
Really?
As a-
I'm surprised
to hear you say that.
Really? Why would you say that?
Well, I would have guessed just because of the way
that you've inspired so many people,
I would have guessed that preaching
might be the default of those three for you.
Preaching is very uncomfortable for me.
I'm much more interested in approval and being liked
to a default in a not so great way.
Like I've made-
Really?
major life decisions based on approval
or doing the socially accepted.
I mean, I was a lawyer for over a decade, you know,
trying to jam a square peg into a round hole
for way too long and very reluctant to get out of it
out of fear of social repercussions
and familial expectations and the like.
And, you know, I would sit
in depositions or in hearings
and just see the gray in everything,
and just felt like I'm a really bad advocate
because I really want to appreciate the nuance
in all of this and can't we just all get along?
Like I'm conflict averse. I'm a people pleaser.
And I host these podcasts and I wanna be challenging
in the conversations,
but also I only have the people on
that I respect and admire.
So I'm sitting here and if I'm being honest,
it's like, I want Adam to like me.
I want him to respect me.
That's like just calling myself out in a vulnerable way
over my own motivations.
(Adam laughing)
And so I spent a lot of time thinking about that.
But I also, I wanna throw
like a little bit of a test case out to you.
So I've been vegan for about 14 years now
and I guess for better or worse,
that's part of my identity.
And I've spent a lot of time thinking
about how I
embody that ethos,
how I carry that message,
how I advocate for something that I believe in.
And I've realized
that for my own personal makeup,
I don't feel, it doesn't feel natural to me
to be a preacher about it.
I'm not interested in taking other people's inventory
and criticizing their decisions.
I don't think it's effective.
And I've kind of settled into a mode
that's a little bit outside of your paradigm,
which is this idea of being kind of a lighthouse.
Like if I live my life well and equip myself as an athlete,
as somebody who is excelling intellectually,
mentally, emotionally, and just living well,
it acts more like a magnet or a tractor beam
that will bring the receptive audience to me
who might be willing or interested to hear about it.
And it also goes back to 12-step
and how I got sober and the tools that I learned
in the program, which are all about not giving advice,
but just sharing your experience.
And so I'm curious about how that fits
into how you think about these ideas
of influencing people and getting people
to kind of open up their minds
and consider different concepts.
Wow.
I think that's brilliant.
I'm kicking myself now
because if we had had this conversation a year ago,
I would have written that into "Think Again".
Oh, well, now I'm bummed.
I wish I'd met you earlier. (laughing)
It's not my idea though,
but it's just something that seems to work better
than any of these other three options.
Although it doesn't start with a P.
(laughing) Yeah.
We need to come up
with a P word for it.
It's not alliterative.
No, I think you articulated it so beautifully though.
It's... there's a lot to react to there.
So I wanna double click on a few things you said.
Let's just start with the lighthouse idea.
I think that that might be the most compelling workaround
that I've, I don't even wanna call it a workaround.
I think that's not doing justice to it.
It's the most compelling solution I can think of
to the tension between what I guess
was my preferred alternative
to preaching, prosecuting, and politicking,
which is thinking like a scientist,
and the need if you want to influence people in the world
to do some preaching.
And I've always been uncomfortable with that tension,
because I guess I should take a step back and just say,
thinking like a scientist is what I would love
for more people to do more often.
And I don't mean you have to go
and wear a white coat all the time
or carry around test tubes or even own a microscope.
What I mean is that just the broadest idea of science
is the pursuit of knowledge and truth.
And if your identity is anchored in being a scientist,
it means that you don't have to stick
to a certain set of beliefs at any one time.
You wanna find out what's gonna be effective
or what the right way is to live your values.
And that means when you form an opinion,
it's a hypothesis.
You can go out and test it. You can observe.
You can interact, you can run experiments.
And the hope is that you're as excited to find out
that you were wrong, as you are to prove
that you were right.
Because either way you've potentially learned something.
And I would argue, even you learn more
when you discover that your hypothesis was false,
than when then when you validate it.
And yet Phil Tetlock, when I talked to him first
about this framework saying,
okay, I want everyone to think more like scientists.
He said, "Well, yeah, but sometimes you have to talk
much more like a preacher in order to be heard."
You know, just look at any pundit on TV
or any leader who gives an inspiring speech.
And I've never liked that as something that you have to do.
And I think you just gave an alternative,
which is to say, okay, I can think like a scientist,
I can test in my own life,
whether I'm gonna be at my best in an iron man
when I go vegan, right?
That's an experiment you ran.
And then once I do that,
if I'm willing to share what I've learned from that,
and I talk about that publicly,
I don't have to tell other people to do it.
I don't have to preach about it.
I'm just telling my story and that will draw people to me.
I think that, I just think that's ingenious.
Author, SriMu plant-based cheese founder,
and my in-house guru and better half
Julie Piatt, aka SriMati,
joined me not once but twice in 2021
dropping wisdom on the importance
of celebrating humanity,
cultivating relationships, and igniting intimacy
in longterm partnerships.
Here's the slice of the spiritual pie
we baked on episode 637.
Humans are amazing. (laughing)
Is that it?
Expound.
No, just because I really feel,
and you really feel,
I mean, there's so much beauty in humanity.
I mean, humans are just, you know,
they're all individual and unique
and resilient and creative and courageous
and empathic and loving and feeling.
And we often hear narratives
that are tearing down the negative
or sort of highlighting all the horrible things
that are going on in our world.
And as we know, we are powerful creators
and where we put our attention is what expands.
And so I feel
that through this timeout
that we've all gone through in the last couple years,
we've even come to appreciate our friends
and our community even deeper,
not only our close friends,
but also our extended communities,
even on social media or through the podcast
or through different mentorship groups
or the SriMu community.
And I think that there's wisdom and power
and intelligence in highlighting
the beauty of humanity.
Because there's a lot more beauty
than what is brought up
for review or to be considered.
And I think it's human, sort of the human tendency
to feel justified
pointing out everything that's wrong.
And then there's something within the personality
or the ego that feels like, oh, you know, see I'm right,
how wrong is that, and this is so wrong,
and this is so wrong.
And so I just think it's a wonderful time.
We're all alive in a body.
Hopefully if you're listening to this podcast
and you're breathing, you have the privilege of being alive,
the privilege of being connected to this podcast
and just to highlight the beauty of humanity
and how all of us have something so meaningful
to bring and offer and share.
Yeah, but I also want to invest more deeply
in my friendships.
You know, I think that's something
that I've overlooked in the past
and something I wanna pay more attention to
because wealth is the company you keep.
And I've been doing that and it's been great
and I feel like I'm in a much better place
than I was last year at this time.
So I feel good.
One of the great opportunities that we have
is to exercise the will
to connect in the face of forced separation.
When you see agendas that are operating
in our world that are seeking to separate,
we have a choice.
We can find a neutrality in understanding
that everything in life is sacred.
Everything comes from divine,
even the things that you consider dark
or the things that you don't agree with.
And if we can sort of relax into that direct connection
with our own source consciousness,
we can stop comparing and trying to analyze a situation
into an intellectual place where we feel safe with it.
And so the work is in the face of separation,
can we be neutral and open and in awe and wonder
and just allow all things?
And it's more of a not this or that or either/or.
It's about a yes and.
Both things can be true from a certain perspective.
And life is full of billions of different kinds
of life forms that are completely unique.
So how could one opinion or one lens
know that it is the way for all things at all times?
I think it's just the fear of the personality
that wants to create a box that gives some certainty.
And I think many of us know and realize now
there is no certainty.
And there really wasn't ever certainty in that way,
but we had things sort of in a place
where we could be in that illusion.
So it really is what you and I just described
is in the constriction, coming into the present moment,
activating neutrality, understanding that everything
comes from a sacred place.
It is all part of the play
and we can find a way
into transformation by going into the separation.
Rather than running away from it or turning away from it,
we can have the courage to go into the experience
with that neutrality.
And if we're lucky, we're probably gonna learn something
or expand or soften or experience something
that maybe we never imagined.
Expert meditation and spiritual teacher,
three-time podcast guest,
and author of one of my favorite daily doses of inspiration,
"Knowing Where to Look", Light Watkins
joined me on episode 603 to talk
about cultivating intuition, and more importantly,
how to have the courage to trust it.
I remember being 29 years old in my kitchen in Harlem
and saying to myself,
"I'm gonna follow my heart no matter what."
And after watching a Chris rock movie. (laughing)
It takes what it takes, man.
No, that story is where you talk
about this idea of wiggle room.
Like, even if you feel like you're on a good path
for yourself, like not holding on too tightly to it
and always making room to be malleable-
To be inspired.
So that you can be available
for the magical opportunity of going to India
in the case of your story.
And it's not about, 'cause some people may hear that
and go, "That's just you not committing
to whatever you said you were gonna do."
And I would refine that and say,
"Well, it's really your feeling
about your path, whatever that is,
whether you have language for it or not
is always gonna be there
but the day-to-day plans may change
about how you get there or what occupation
or what family lifestyle choices
you have to go through in order to get there.
And so that's where you wanna be malleable
and be open to inspiration.
Not in questioning the ultimate goal or plan.
You really can't go wrong
if you just keep following
whatever you think inside.
Sure, but you also
can't expect to be smiled upon by perhaps your peers
and your colleagues.
Because that will-
No, it takes you
completely away from social proof.
You're gonna look like a dilettante.
You know what I mean?
Like, oh, this guy just goes from one thing to the next.
He can't really stick with anything.
Did you read
David Epstein's book "Range"?
No.
So it's a very interesting
kind of study
of a variety of people
who have excelled in different fields
from science and education
to athletics and art, et cetera.
And it belies
this sort of Malcolm Gladwell myth
of the 10,000-Hour Rule
and demonstrates that there are those people,
of course, the Tiger Woods and people like that.
But by and large,
most people who are fully expressed and excelling
at the highest level of their specialized field
are people who earlier in life
did lots of different stuff and were the people
who just really couldn't commit to anything.
And as a result, they develop this robustness of experience
that back to that idea of in retrospect,
all the dots line up,
make perfect sense with where they end up,
but they're people of varied interests
and many different passions
who developed that capacity early
to be malleable and flexible,
to have that wiggle room.
And it's those people that we look at now
as lazy dilettantes,
who ultimately it's reframing that
and saying, well, and you talk about this.
Like how do you suspend judgment in the book?
Maybe they're like we should look at this
a little bit differently.
Perhaps they're in their exploratory phase
and they're gonna to be magnificent and amazing
and world changing in something that they finally latch onto
later in life.
Yeah, there is a story in there about how (chuckles),
I talk about leaving that first job
for the reasons that I left.
And then while I was writing,
I remember the day I wrote that story,
I was in an Airbnb, I think it was in London,
living out of a backpack,
didn't own anything, still don't own anything.
I've got a little money saved up,
but I had less saved up at the time.
And I was like, you know, compared to my peers,
I don't really, I haven't succeeded.
I haven't really done anything,
that led to material, the material success
that we kind of aspire towards today,
but I've never felt more fulfilled.
And I realized that the true wealth
is the fulfillment inside, right?
And that's, again, this is a living experiment. (chuckles)
Yeah.
And it's not
that I'm like walking around
beaming all the time because I feel fulfilled inside.
That's not really what we're talking about.
It's just, it's having this inner security
that wherever you are
is where you're supposed to be.
And if that means you get challenged in certain ways,
then that challenge is there for you
to learn something new about yourself.
And that new thing that you learn is going to add
to the feeling tone of fulfillment, right?
And so that's the underlying message
of this whole path is your path is not leading you
to more success or more comfort.
It's leading you to know yourself better
and ultimately to feel your connection with other people.
And that could be a very, very treacherous path
at some points.
Could be incredibly uncomfortable at other points.
But the happiness that people tend to look for outside
in success is much more temporal
compared to what can feel inside
while you're going through all of those other moments
and obstacles in life.
All right, people, up next
is one of the world's leading authorities
on the neuroscience of addiction, Anna Lembke MD,
author of two important books, "Drug Dealer MD"
and her newest work "Dopamine Nation",
in episode 623, she gave us a powerful primer
on why the relentless pursuit of pleasure
always leads to pain.
For so long we've had this idea
that addiction is a downstream consequence
of some other problem.
But addiction is its own problem.
You can have a perfect life and get very, very addicted.
Yeah, yeah, that's a really important point.
You know I've had conversations with Gabor Mate
and for him, it's all about childhood trauma.
Resolve that, you resolve the addiction.
I had Johann Hari here.
For him, it's all about lost connections,
your connectivity to your friends and your family
and your community.
And I think those are important pieces in this puzzle,
but I'm reluctant
to be reductionist
about the role that those play
in the broader context of addiction.
Thank you so much for invoking those examples
because that shows me that you perfectly understand
what I'm trying to communicate here.
Because, yes, it's true that childhood trauma
increases your risk for developing addiction.
Yes, it's true that addiction leads to isolation
and that the antidote to addiction
is social connection in part.
But what is so important to understand
is you can have the perfect childhood,
the perfect parents,
the greatest social network,
the best spouse, wonderful kids,
and you can get really, really addicted.
And that is so important for people to understand
and also healthcare providers.
Because everybody's sort of looking
for the reason behind the addiction,
but there doesn't have to be a reason behind addiction.
Addiction just can be on its own.
Yeah, I think that's a crucial point.
I mean, I get asked very frequently,
like, "What do you think caused this?
What is the source of your addiction?"
And I'm heavily indoctrinated in 12-step
and I'm sure I have some biases around that
but one of the things that you learn
is that it's fine if you wanna psychoanalyze
that aspect of your origin story,
but ultimately it doesn't avail you with the tools
for how to live today
and how to move productively forward.
And there is an argument to be made that it's sort of
a fool's errand to spend too much time on that.
Yes. Insight can be the booby prize.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, this is a really very, very important concept.
And the other reason it's important
is because I think we're natural storytellers
and we want to rationalize irrational behavior.
And so the first thing that we try to do
when we are doing something that's irrational
and self and other destructive,
is to tell ourselves a story
or have someone else tell us a story
about why we would do that crazy thing.
And if we can solve that equation,
then suddenly every everything makes sense
and you can figure this out.
It doesn't work that way.
No, no.
I mean, I have had over 20 plus years,
countless patients come into my office
and say, Dr. Lembke,
the reason that I'm addicted to alcohol
or I'm addicted to cannabis or I'm a compulsive gambler
is because I'm depressed and anxious.
And if you would just fix that,
then I wouldn't have that other problem.
And what I have to do is say to them,
you know what, I wish that were true.
But here's the truth, number one,
even if I could magically wave my wand
and make your depression and anxiety go away,
once you're addicted, you're addicted.
And if we don't focus on that problem,
that's not gonna get better.
The other thing is that relationship
between psychological symptoms and addiction,
it's complicated and it's not necessarily
that the depression comes first
and then the addiction comes.
Addiction can lead to depression, anxiety,
which is why my first intervention so often
is to have people abstain.
But I'll never forget a patient of mine who said,
"You know, Dr. Lembke,
I realized I was an alcoholic
when I got started on an antidepressant,
wasn't depressed anymore, but kept drinking.
That was his aha moment because he was like,
"Oh, I thought I was drinking 'cause I was depressed.
But when I stopped being depressed, I was still drinking."
Yeah, that's kind of the genius
behind your dual diagnosis clinic, right?
It's almost a Trojan horse way of just treating addiction
because the way you get them in the door
in a non-threatening way is under the rubric
of treating their anxiety or depression, et cetera.
Right, yes.
Although it's not without effort
because people are resistant to that idea.
They come in and they want help with depression, anxiety.
They see the addiction as a secondary problem.
And it takes all my powers of persuasion
to get them onboard.
(both laughing)
Yeah, none too happy to be told
that you can't deal with your conditioned acts
until we deal with this substance
or behavioral addiction that you have
and they storm out,
and leave a one-star Yelp review or something.
Exactly. You've got it exactly.
You understand.
(both laughing)
Yeah, people don't wanna hear that you know.
It's interesting.
That piece, I mean, as a psychiatrist though,
you must have honed tools for how to communicate
with people to kinda crack that core.
Yes.
And the key piece is to be empathic
at the same time that you're telling people
what they don't wanna hear.
You know what I mean?
That's tough.
That's a tightrope walk.
It is, it is,
but I feel like I've gotten pretty good at it.
Having teenagers also helps
to sort of, you breathe and you stay calm
and you say, "I understand what you're saying."
So the typical sort of validating first.
But then you give them kind of the real deal,
you know, what the science shows,
what my clinical experience shows,
what I'm asking them to experiment with
so that they can gather their own data
and see if what I'm saying is right.
But on the data piece, I mean, this doesn't operate
in a logical framework.
It's an emotional framework.
And timing is so important, right?
Like I'm happy to talk sobriety with anyone who's suffering,
but I've learned to detach from any expectations
of what they will or won't do.
Like people get sober when they're ready to.
Yeah.
And one of the main things I have to teach my trainees,
my fellows, is that an essential part
of the work that we do
is that we have to actually really care about our patients,
but there is a point at which you can care too much.
And when we're trying harder than the patient is,
or wanting it more than the patient wants it,
we're not actually helping them.
Then you gotta go to the Al-Anon meeting.
That's right. That was good.
(Rich laughing)
Or we have to conduct our own little Al-Anon session,
you know, right there at work.
'Cause I work with a bunch of young folks,
which I can say is one of the most exciting things
that's happened in the last 10 years.
You know, 10 years ago, I couldn't find a medical student
under a rock who wanted to learn about addiction.
Now they're beating down my door,
which is really awesome.
Yeah, I think it brings up
an important kind of broader point
about culture in general
and this idea that we live in a situation
in which we are,
there's this asymmetry
in terms of how we approach our lives
with respect to pleasure and pain.
And we organize our lives completely around the pursuit
of pleasure and the avoidance of pain.
But as you kind of astutely put in the book,
the more that we pursue that,
ultimately the more pain that we reap.
Because these systems require a level of homeostasis
that we're constantly trying to avoid
so we're just delaying the inevitable onslaught of pain
that we so fear.
Yes, absolutely.
We live in a world in which we are saturated with dopamine
and we live in a culture which encourages us to pursue it.
But the ultimate end result of pursuing dopamine
is to feel worse than when you started.
And this is really the central message.
People are more depressed, more anxious,
more suicidal, and more addicted
than they were 30 years ago.
And I contend that one of the main reasons
is because of this relentless pursuit of pleasure
that essentially adjusts the dopamine levels,
changes the hedonic or pleasure set point
to make people anhedonic meaning without joy.
The godfather of integrative medicine
and a true pioneer of health, Dr. Andrew Weil
is a legend in the realm of mind/body healing.
In the 606 drop, we talked psychedelics,
fungi, food, and breath,
and the best practices you can adopt
to sidestep chronic lifestyle disease.
What goes on in your mind
really determines and shapes your experience
of the external world.
And I've applied that very much in my work with patients
because I just find over and over again
that the root causes of illness are often
in the mental-emotional sphere and not in the physical body,
or like they're in both.
But conventional medicine has so ignored
that non-physical part of ourselves
and I think that's a great limitation.
Yeah, I mean, I think one of the things
I appreciate about you the most is just
that level of cognizance and emphasis
that you put on the mind and your willingness
to delve deep into the nature of consciousness.
And these are just anathema
in conventional medical practice.
Yeah. It just doesn't compute.
I took, one of the most interesting courses
I ever took was in medical hypnosis
at Columbia University, it was for physicians.
I learned so many fascinating things there.
And as a result of that, I made mind-body medicine,
a major component of the integrative medicine curriculum
that I developed.
And I very frequently refer patients
to mind-body practitioners,
whether that's hypnotherapists
or visualization practitioners
or any one of a number of other modalities,
because I find these things to be incredibly effective,
cost-effective, I mean, even fun
for both practitioner and patient.
And relatively free of risk.
Totally. And they are so underutilized in medicine.
And I remember once I was challenged to a public debate
by Arnold Relman,
who was the editor of "The New England Journal of Medicine".
And it was a very publicized event.
And I mean, I have never met a more closed-minded person.
His position was all you have to do is show me the evidence.
You know, you show me the evidence, blah, blah, blah.
So anything you'd show him, he'd say,
"Oh, well, that's not evidence."
And one of the questions that I asked him,
I said that the best researched area of what I do
is mind-body interaction.
There's been 30 years of studies on that.
And yet these modalities are so underutilized.
What would you do to increase their use?
And his response was, "There is no evidence
for mind-body interactions."
So, you know, (chuckles) I don't know
what you can do with that.
Yeah, I mean, how are you...
Yeah, there's a profound hubris
around the scientific method.
Science is truth. Science is fact.
But that overlooks the fact that it's not,
it's a method.
Yeah.
It's not a fact in and of itself.
It's a means of approximating truth.
It's a way to approach or discover truth
but it's also not the sole method and it's flawed.
And I think there's so much arrogance
around this is the way that we do it.
And that kind of approach
is very dualistic or binary
in that it's controlling for this variable
or this and that.
And obviously we've made, I'm not dismissing it.
It's like, this is-
No, of course.
the engine of progress, of course.
But it overlooks the holistic nature of the human body
and the interplay
between all of these very sensitive systems.
And science and medicine in our part of the world
are totally, totally dominated by materialism.
You know, a philosophy that says
that the only thing that's real is that which can be seen
and touched and measured.
And that if you see a change in a physical system,
the cause has to be physical.
Non-physical causation of physical events doesn't compute.
It's not allowed for.
So, in hypnosis there are so many demonstrations,
like you can touch a person with a finger
and you have them believe it's a piece of red, hot metal
and if they're in a deep trance,
they get an actual blister.
I mean, that is non-physical causation of a physical event.
So if you try to get a doctor to look at that or scientists,
oh, it's just a curious thing.
It doesn't have any meaning.
Yeah, that kind of makes me think
of your interesting ideas around the placebo effect
and the way that we kind of think
about that backwards.
Fortunately, that's one of the things that's changing now,
which makes me very happy.
But still the most common ways
I hear the word placebo used are in phrases
like how do you know that's not just a placebo effect
and the most interesting word there is just.
Or we have to rule out the placebo effect.
That's what we wanna rule in.
The placebo response is pure healing from within
mediated by the mind,
unmixed up with the direct effects of treatment,
which are likely to be harmful.
Yeah, I think I've heard you talk
about the fact that in every kind
of double blind trial-
Yes, exactly.
if you look
at the placebo group, there's always a few people
that have experienced the result
as if they had taken-
All of the changes.
Exactly. All of it.
And that's the most interesting thing
of the whole thing.
Amazing that any change
we can produce with a pharmacological agent
can be exactly mimicked
in at least some people,
some of the time by a mind mediated mechanism.
So fortunately the change that's happened,
and this is the result
of these new brain imaging technologies,
is that now you can show that certain parts
of the brain are active
when people have placebo responses
and this makes it accessible and real to people.
So I think placebos are being taken much more seriously.
Right, because now the imaging science
has caught up and neuroscience has progressed to the point
where they can provide an explanation that makes sense
to the conventional
kind of community.
Exactly.
And the same thing's happened with meditation.
There've been a tremendous number of studies
of very longtime serious meditators
showing different activity in different brain areas
as a result.
So the fact that a meditation practice
can actually physically change the brain,
I mean, that's really interesting stuff.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
But within that,
there's this profound, deep appreciation
for the mystical, right?
Yes. Yeah.
Which is like my favorite thing to talk about.
Oh good. (laughing)
And I suspect that was in part informed
by all these shamans and various healing practitioners
that you've experienced over the decades
in South America and Asia, et cetera.
One of the attitudes that I just can't stand
is that when scientists believe that it's their job
to make mystery go away.
You know, it seems to me, mystery is an essential aspect
of the universe,
and that you have to appreciate that and wonder at it.
Once, Terence McKenna, I once heard say
that the bigger you build the fire,
the more you're aware of the extent of the darkness.
And I think that's true.
And I think
that our experience,
at the heart of our experience is mystery,
the stuff that we can appreciate
but we can't really understand with our mind.
Right.
What does it mean to be human?
How do you be a good person?
What happens when you die?
If you find yourself grappling with these big questions,
then my audio experiment with Rainn Wilson
and Reza Aslan, hosts of "Metaphysical Milkshake"
back on episode 633 is definitely your jam.
Here's a little something to whet your appetite.
I believe that everyone has a purpose.
I believe this with all of my heart
and in a very strong way.
Because as a member of the Baha'i faith,
but not just of Baha'i faith,
I think anyone who has...
I mean, I think that's an answer that applies
to both theists and atheists.
But as a member of the Baha'i faith,
I believe that we are on an eternal spiritual journey,
that this, our, whatever our soul,
our eternal part of ourselves
is encased in this flesh tuxedo for 80 or 90 years,
we slough it off and we continue our journey
beyond time and space.
So while we're here, everyone has a purpose.
Now, it may not be like everyone on planet earth
has a purpose like Oprah has a purpose.
I mean, it's about finding-
We can't all be Oprah.
(laughing) We can't have-
There's Oprah. (indistinct)
seven billion Oprah's on the planet.
But I do think that this is one
of the really exciting tasks
is there's a question wrapped,
there's a riddle wrapped inside this question,
which is our purpose is to find our purpose.
And as soon as we've found our purpose,
we have to be not sure that that's our purpose,
and we have to keep finding our purpose.
So by the time we're 97 and we keel over,
hopefully we're all continuously
on this, at the very beginning footsteps
of this eternal journey toward finding
what that purpose is and it may shift and change.
And so whether you call that,
you know, God, or the great spirit,
or just the power of the universe,
or the winds of the cosmos,
or the mystic connection,
or whatever you wanna call God,
which has become a four-letter word
and is a tough concept to dig into.
But the winds, the holy spirit,
the winds of the cosmic power
of the creative force that surrounds us,
that's within us, without us, beyond us,
beyond limitations of time and space,
this has a, these winds have a very special...
We have a very special relationship with them, I believe.
And it's like when you go sailing,
I don't know anything about sailing.
I've been sailing like twice.
But the whole idea that you tack your sails
to try and get the most out of the wind,
depending on, you have a vague,
you know, I wanna go toward that island,
but you may not go directly to the island.
The winds may take you off to the left a little bit,
and then back or you may have to zigzag.
The winds stall for a little bit.
You turn on your motor,
then the winds are pushing you right there,
but you are trying to align yourself
with those winds.
And it's really, it's exciting.
I think it's a really exciting part of being alive,
maybe the most exciting part of being alive.
And this is where I think that young people especially,
I don't know about older people.
I mean, older people, we get set in our ways.
and like Reza said, we've got kids and jobs and mortgages,
and kind of we have a little bit of stuff figured out.
But especially for this mental health crisis
that is afflicting kids under 20 or 30,
it's astonishingly insidious
and toxic and fatal.
But this, this connection to this question
is a big part of helping
to use a spiritual tool to solve that issue,
solve the problem.
Beautifully put.
Hard agree.
Thanks. Can we just end the podcast now?
Yeah, boom.
The only thing that I will just say
to people who are listening to this,
because I could have listened to that all day.
It's a hundred percent true.
Aw, thanks, Reza.
I agree with it a hundred percent
and I have like philosophical and theological reasons
why I agree with it and experiential reasons
why I agree with it.
But what I'll just say is that
if you are listening to this and saying,
okay, fine, everybody has a purpose,
well then, you know, how do I,
am I doing my purpose?
How do I know what my purpose is?
If you don't know, then you're not doing it.
It's, for those people,
like I feel like I am achieving my purpose.
I would say, probably you too, Rich, yeah?
Rainn.
I mean, you're doing what your purpose is.
I wrestle with it, truth be told,
but yes, by and large, I do, and it's just-
Well I mean you-
It's a constant, for me a constant,
a series of the, use going back to the sailboat metaphor,
adjusting those sails.
That's what I was just
gonna say, yeah.
But that metaphor is so perfect
because everyone who has had this experience
will tell you that when the wind is right
and your sail is exactly where it's supposed to be,
and you're moving smoothly,
and I mean, this metaphorically not actually on the water
but I mean in life, you know it.
You know it.
And you always know when you're fighting the wind.
So pay attention to that feeling.
Yeah.
Pay attention to that.
If you were sitting there thinking to yourself,
well, then how do I know what my purpose is?
Are you fighting the wind?
Is that what it feels like?
Then you're not pursuing your purpose.
Have a mission, not a job.
And I say this to my students all the time.
'Cause I think so many of us pursue jobs.
I wanna be an actor. That's what my passion is.
I wanna be a writer. That's where my passion is.
That's great.
But what's your mission?
You know, your mission is bigger
than the things that you do, right?
If you have a mission,
then you can have multiple ways
in which that mission expresses itself
like acting or writing
or service or whatever the thing is.
So, you know, if you're sitting there
and you're thinking to yourself,
what do I wanna do with my life?
Tweak that question just a little bit.
What is your mission in life.
Pursue that mission and I promise you-
Doors will open.
people will pay you for it,
(chuckles) you know.
But it's the rare individual
who has a grip on that, right?
I feel like, especially with young people,
like you have to live some life.
Like you have to travel,
you have to collect experiences.
You have to put yourself out there.
How could you possibly-
Yeah, absolutely.
It's not gonna, it's not a thunderbolt.
I mean, there's always the kid who at age six
knows what he or she wants to do,
but that's really the outlier.
Really.
Well, this is what I always say when I,
'cause I do some speaking at college campuses and stuff too.
And I just tell people like, 20s are a waste of time.
Like don't even worry about it.
Don't try and get it figured out.
Like the point of your 20s is to try 12 different things
and fail at nine of them
so that you can come out.
But there's all this
societal pressure of like...
(water pouring)
That's not urination by the way,
if you're hearing that
(Rich laughing)
in the microphone
That's Reza pouring a glass of water.
There's no proof of that.
But truthfully in society right now,
you talk to so many college kids
and they're so depressed at 20, 21
'cause they haven't gotten the perfect internship
over the summer and they're not pre-enrolled
in the perfect grad program
and they don't have their job aligned.
Now, I know it's hard to make a living out there.
It's hard to have a career and make a living.
It's much harder than in the '80s and '90s
when we were getting our educations.
But nonetheless, if you view the 20s as a workshop stage,
then it gives you some, so you can relax a little bit.
But you gotta do some counter-programming around that.
You're asking young people to step off the hamster wheel
and that's pretty scary, especially for a kid
who's kind of been on that track
where it's like get into the right college,
get the right job.
And then, oh, if I opt out of that,
then life's gonna pass me by.
But obviously it's quite the contrary.
Yeah.
And I think too,
for mission, and we've been on this topic too long, but-
Yeah, we're gonna have to pick another thing.
I think, here you go, Reza.
I just think in terms of mission too,
it doesn't have to be grand.
You know, like we don't all have to change the world.
Your mission can be I wanna build beautiful things
out of wood and I wanna have a nice family.
That's exactly what I mean.
Yeah, my mission from a very early age
was to change the way
that people think through stories.
I didn't say to myself, I'm gonna be a writer.
I'm gonna be a television producer.
I'm gonna be like a podcast host.
But all of those are just different ways
of telling stories to change the way that people think.
So those are the jobs that I do,
but the mission is something else.
Yeah.
Hm, that's great.
Beyond politics and religion,
few topics are more hotly debated than nutrition.
So to help us parse facts from fiction
and guide us towards an evidence-based
rational model for nutritional health,
I convened with my friend Simon Hill,
author of "The Proof is in the Plants" on episode 638.
Here is a tasty morsel.
I'm big on diet quality
being more important than focusing too much
on the macronutrients.
The macronutrients can get, can be important
if you have a very specific goal,
and for example, athletes or bodybuilders, et cetera.
But I think what's more important first
is the quality of those macronutrients,
the quality of the fat,
the quality of the carbohydrates.
It's less jelly beans, more black beans.
The quality of the protein.
That's my favorite quote
of yours by the way.
So where, there are
a lot of people that are very anti-carbohydrates,
but carbohydrates is a, it's an umbrella term.
And what matters
is where you're getting those carbohydrates from.
If they're coming from jelly beans,
then you're going to run into problems.
Right, this idea,
in terms of kind of falsified narratives
out there vilifying all carbohydrates,
lumping in the black beans
with the jelly beans is preposterous
or analogizing fruit to diet soda
or soda, sugar soda.
Mm-hm.
Yeah.
We've talked extensively on this podcast
about protein, meeting your protein needs
on a plant-based diet
so I don't wanna belabor the point,
but I haven't had you here to do it.
And you being a very strong physical specimen,
I think it's worthy if somebody's tuning into this
and isn't familiar with either of us
and perhaps this is their first introduction
to some of the ideas we're talking about
to at least spend a couple minutes
talking about the big protein question.
Because it still propagates, in terms of people
who are interested in moving towards
a more plant-centric diet but are fearful
of what that implies in terms of meeting
their protein needs,
especially for the active people amongst that cohort.
Yeah, so this was a very large fear of mine (chuckles)
when I was initially making the changes to my diet.
And I always remind myself of that
because it's easy to kinda dismiss it
and forget that, you know,
the sort of general school of thought
is that you get your protein from animal foods
and that plants are missing protein.
And to this day,
when you go to a restaurant or you go to Chipotle,
they say, "What protein do you want on this?"
And yeah, very rarely does that include plant protein.
Although that's, you know, it's starting to change.
I think the food environment's
starting to modify-
Definitely.
and we're seeing increases in plant protein options.
And I was chatting with Paul Shapiro
couple weeks ago now, and he's doing exciting things
with mycoprotein.
Yeah, it's pretty wild
what his company is doing right now with mushrooms.
Yeah. It's crazy.
You know, feeding these fungi microbes,
potato and sorghum,
and then producing this super protein-rich food.
I tried some as well and it's incredible.
I haven't tried it yet.
You know, that's certainly the future of food.
But overall I think there are
a few aspects of protein
that are somewhat misunderstood.
And we can perhaps clear up some of that confusion.
The first would be that plant protein
is missing certain essential amino acids.
And protein is made up of amino acids.
They're the little building blocks
and our body can make 11 of them
and the other nine are considered essential amino acids.
We have to get them through our food.
And the idea for many decades
has been that plants are missing
some of those amino acids.
And you hear this idea of complete protein, right?
And often people speak to quinoa and soy.
And I think definition here is really important.
It's critical to this.
Because I think there's a misunderstanding
of what complete protein means.
I think most people think,
okay, well, if quinoa and soy are complete proteins,
that means that these other plants
are missing amino acids.
They're inferior.
Yeah, or that they're just totally missing something
and that's not true.
So all plants contain all nine essential amino acids.
They're not missing.
There just are some of those plants
where certain amino acids are in lower amounts.
And so the definition of incomplete
actually by definition within the science,
although it's not used this way in general conversation,
is not that an amino acid is missing,
it's just that it is in a smaller percentage.
And if you were to eat only that food
for all of your calories,
then you might run into some trouble.
You might not consume enough
of a certain amino acid
to meet your body's daily requirement.
So you can imagine
that that's kind of a useful definition
for developing countries,
places where there is food security problems.
And if someone's living on one or two foods,
then that's important.
But if you're eating a diet where you have a range
of an abundance of food options,
then really it's not that helpful.
And so if you are eating
with diversity, you will,
you might be consuming for example,
grains that are low in lysine.
And look, it's true.
If you were to eat certain grains
and that was providing
your 3000, two thousand and a half thousand calories,
then you might fall short on lysine.
And the same could be said about certain beans.
If you eat a certain bean for all of your calories,
you might fall short on the thiamine.
But beans are very rich in lysine.
And when you start adding all these foods into your diet,
some might be low in a certain amino acid,
but the other food is really high.
Right, it's really an academic exercise
because almost no one is only eating one food.
Correct.
Unless you're like
the Spud Fit guy,
who's eating just potatoes for a year.
Or you are in a developing country
and there is a legitimate food scarcity issue.
But almost everybody is eating
at least two, three, five,
six, seven, 10 different foods
throughout the course of a day or two.
And if you're doing that,
you're rating with that diversity
and you're eating enough calories,
you will not run into problems.
You will get all of the essential amino acids
that your body needs.
And anyone can run a simple exercise.
Don't believe me. Download the Cronometer app.
It's a free app.
Plug in a day of eating
and you will quickly see that you will exceed
the hundred percent recommended amount
for all nine essential amino acids.
And you'll see, it's very hard not to exceed. (chuckles)
It would be more challenging to fall short on them
than it would be to consume enough of them.
All right, people of Podcastlandia, we did it.
This is the end.
And to put a cap on part one of this year's recap
is none other than planetary change agent
and entrepreneur, Paul Hawkin,
who joined me back on episode 627
to share his beautiful new book,
"Regeneration: Ending the Climate Crisis in One Generation".
Paul is someone who has indelibly shaped my perspective
and my actions when it comes to ecological responsibility.
And it's just an honor to close things out
with his words today.
The root cause of global warming
is a massive disconnections
between each other, between people,
between people and nature,
and nature itself, which is caused by humans,
habitat fragmentation, pollution,
acidification of the oceans, and onwards.
So regenerating and reversing
the climate crisis is really about reconnecting
those broken strands.
And that's what the solutions really are
as opposed to sort of standalone techniques
or technologies that's going to fix it.
That word fix doesn't even belong in the conversation
because it's not an it, and you can't fix it.
The atmosphere is the biosphere.
It does the same thing and we are part of it.
And nature never makes a mistake, only we do.
So let's look at what we're doing.
And regeneration is very much about alignment
with the living world,
with the way it works and always has.
And so, as you said,
what we've done conversationally and sort of declaratively
and almost imperatively
is individuate the problem,
which is this is what you can do or should do.
And it's true, those are good things.
You know, recycling and use cold water
in your washing machine,
and try not to, drive an EV if you can afford it,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I think people understand
that even if they do them,
they know it's not sufficient
to the task at hand.
And so it actually makes people more disempowered
in a funny way,
even though they're actually participating
in their kind of token way.
And then they look to governments,
they look to the Conference of the Parties,
the UN Framework on Climate Change.
They look for these annual meetings,
there's one in Glasgow in November,
for something to happen.
Like hoping that politicians
will get together and solve the problem.
If politicians knew what to do,
we wouldn't be in the situation we are today.
And that's just not gonna happen.
Not to say we can't say it, but you know.
So then you feel like there's this gulf
between these huge meta-institutions,
corporations and governments,
and then you as an individual.
And that's what, again, what "Regeneration"
is trying to say.
Whoa, wait a minute.
That's not where the solution is gonna come from,
you know.
Right.
"Regeneration" is sort of bedfellows
with this idea of symbiosis.
Like how can we live more symbiotically on the planet?
And understanding that and really embodying that
begins with really fully embracing
and acknowledging that we are all
microsystems that are a part of a macrosystem.
And it's sort of belying the idea
that nature's over there and we're over here
and we venture into nature and out of nature.
And yet fundamentally that's just a falsehood
because the cells in our body
and everything that we're made up of
is of course part and parcel of this environment.
And in terms of the solution, once you acknowledge that,
I think what you begin to understand
and what the book kind of does a beautiful job conveying
is the idea
that there's this...
The problem is systemic,
that we can't truly move
into this more symbiotic regenerative relationship
with the planet until we have some corrective measures
with our systems at large, right?
There's this gigantic misalignment of incentives
across the board, be it by dint of governmental bodies
or the tectonic plates of capitalism,
all of these forces that the individual
feels powerless to have any control over or say over
that perpetuate the problem.
So short of revolution,
like how are we creating better incentives
for the systems that are in play?
Or how do we create better systems with incentives
that could supplant the systems that are leading us astray?
That is the question.
And I think that
between the individual and meta-institutions,
global institutions, is something else called agency.
And agency is sort of been overlooked.
There is no such thing as an individual.
That's sort of a delusion
we wake up with in the morning. (laughing)
But functionally, there's no such thing.
And every person has agency.
It's their family, it's their friends, it's their community,
it's their neighborhood,
it's their church, it's their synagogue,
it's a school, it's where they teach,
it's their city, it's their company, colleagues.
It goes on and on and on.
And we have a network.
We're all part of networks
and that is where we have influence
and where we can make a difference.
And the, I think a lot of people have felt
or come to think that if we get renewables right
or we do this, we do that, that again, we'll fix it.
But like there's some Archimedean solution.
If we pull hard enough,
the problem is gonna go away.
Right.
And rather than understanding that the solution
is everywhere, it's ubiquitous, it's local,
regional, it's where agency exists
and that is everywhere on earth with every culture,
every society, and every country.
And so that's the good news,
which is that we can solve this.
We really can.
But we can't solve it
if we think someone's gonna solve it for us.
Or if we come to believe that individuals
are to blame and that they're responsible
and they'll solve it.
We kinda know that one's not true.
Right.
I'm not saying we don't have personal responsibility.
Of course we do.
But that that alone is going to be sufficient.
And so when we look at the institutions
and with the perverse incentives that they have,
the economic institutions, the political institutions,
they are all extractive.
That is to say every institution that we've come to know
and trust or not trust, but buy from, or believe in,
or invest in, or own shares in is extractive.
You know, it's just taking life.
And we sorta take that for granted that.
You know, well, don't make a mess. (chuckles)
You know.
Or clean up your mess, that kind of thing.
And that's sustainability in a way.
But extraction is taking life
and when you take life, that's degeneration.
That's what degeneration is when you take life.
And so "Regeneration" is really
not about blaming
and sort of demonizing
those institutions or those economic sectors so much
as saying wait, that road,
that degeneration road, doesn't go much further.
Everything's screaming at us, all the science,
our experiences, and so forth.
Like that road doesn't go much further.
Why are we going down that road?
And so "Regeneration" is about a 180 pivot.
Like, can we just stop and go the other way?
Can we not regenerate the world
and have a GDP and an economy and jobs
rather than degenerate it?
And the fact is we can,
and it's really a question of healing the future
or stealing the future.
'Cause what we're doing is stealing the future.
Now, it used to be from our children,
now it's from ourselves practically.
And so it really isn't like
I could say something that what's happening
with respect to climate is wrong or...
Not at all. It's all great.
What everybody's doing is fantastic.
But unless we actually do address
those institutional incentives,
and actually assumptions that are so deep
that people don't even understand them as assumptions,
then we won't have a chance at all.
Because the, and you know, Rich,
one of the things too,
go back to the fix it thing.
Like, you know Bill Gates and others,
like John Kerry, for example, are saying,
if we don't do nuclear, we're screwed, okay? (laughing)
And this idea that there is this one thing.
But you could have renewable energy
or nuclear energy for the whole world today
and we'd still be going right over the cliff
because we're destroying all the living systems on earth.
We're destroying our oceans, our fisheries, our land,
our forest, our insects, our pollinators, and so forth.
That has nothing to do with renewable energy
or fossil fuel energy.
That has to do with us.
And so we have to see it, as you said earlier,
as a system, it's whole.
You can't silo it and separate it out
and say we're gonna do that and do this and do that.
You can do that,
but unless you step back and look at it systemically,
you're not gonna get to the core cause or core cure.
What an incredible year.
Thank you for joining me today.
I hope you enjoyed this look in the rear view.
Links to all the full episodes
and the social media accounts
for all the guests excerpted today
can be found in the show notes
and on the episode page at richroll.com.
Part two with a bunch more awesome excerpted convos
will be up later in the week
so stay tuned for that.
And if you'd like to support the podcast,
the easiest and most impactful thing you can do
is to subscribe to the show on YouTube,
Apple Podcast, Spotify, and the like.
Sharing the show or your favorite episodes with friends
or on social media is of course always appreciated.
And finally, for podcast updates, special offers on books,
the meal planner, and other subjects,
you can subscribe to our newsletter,
which you can find on the footer of any page
on richroll.com.
Today's show is produced and engineered
by Jason Camiolo.
The video edition of the show was created
by Dan Drake and Blake Curtis.
Portraits by Davy Greenberg and Grayson Wilder.
Graphic elements courtesy of Daniel Solis.
And our theme music
(light guitar music)
was created by Tyler Piatt, Trapper Piatt, and Harry Mathis.
Appreciate the love and support.
I will see you back here in a couple days
with part two of our "Best of 2021".
Until then, relax.
It's okay to take a break,
pause when agitated,
try to enjoy the holidays.
Peace. Plants.
Namaste.